par
ailleurs alors déjà moi je pense voilà
non mais je pense que les vidéos elles
sont elles sont sortis puis qu'il ya des
gens voilà qui ont qui les ont envoyés
ici les envoie pas exactement est
clairement moyens mais qui a dit
yachvili tuer je vais faire sortir
qu'est ce qui s'est passé alors s'il dit
pour vous parce que vous êtes l'avocat
de m c'est parce qu'ils aient bâtir moi
je regrette que ce monsieur ne soit pas
en face à face à moi finalement ça
prouve qu'ils iront pas courageux vers
ces biens qui bat une fête d'ailleurs ce
qu'elle cache pas que max ne s'était pas
été lui qui voulait pas être en face de
vous donc mais si moi je n'ai pas de
problème on va leur demander de revenir
dans les six derniers affrontements
j'ai trouvé là parce que je représente
ma cliente aujourd'hui qu'un beau
dramatiser au savoir que l scarifié
qu'elle a fait doté de suicides à la
suite à l'issue de cette affaire de
cette vidéo est ce de cette affaire qui
l'a complètement traumatisée elle est
déprimée elle n'est pas bien et surtout
il faut savoir que il raconte n'importe
quoi et je veux dire pourquoi parce que
personne ne s'est fait un nom à nous
raconter sa version dans un assaut
d'accord mais non mais justement
malaisie dit nous savons est donc
simplement elle lui a dressé après cette
ce spectacle et 7 cette horreur qu'elle
a vécu et ils réussirent sms une fois
qu'il était sorti de l'appartement en
dedans toute façon je te laisserai pas
comme ça je t'attaque rat penat je ne te
laisserai pas faire je veux saisir un
avocat et ce sms à déclencher c'est
justement une peur il dû réfléchir
comment faire pour finalement anticipé
une éventuelle plainte pénale je pense
que c'est sa création la vraie version
juteux qui expliquerait pourquoi il est
cette vidéo c'est lui qui est juste on
veut savoir nous c'est quoi cette
histoire c'est quoi cette soirée se
passe quoi il en arrive là quoi
l'histoire alors mal histoire simplement
que c'est des gamins ils sont ils sont
petites fêtes ils ont bu un peu et ils
ont converti matin pardon à 11h12 non
non et s'était pas levé en zone à ok
c'était en pleine nuit vers 3 4 heures
du matin à peu près des grands de la
vidéo on la voit
normal si je puis dire heureuse était
vers 3 heures du matin donc ça va partir
trois heures du matin trois heures à 5
heures du matin donc il les a attirés il
a attiré jeune fille dont qu'ils ont
attiré ces jeunes hommes ces jeunes
filles dans un appart hôtels et donc
voilà on va finir la soirée là bas boire
un verre ya une piscine c'est sympa un
film ou un piscine pourquoi pas avant
ceux des jeunes en vain entre 20 et 23
ans bon donc ils se rendent là bas et
une fois là bas cette petite jeune fille
adorable et chine est magnifique alors
elle fait quoi dans la vie étudiante
elle allait en 3e année de l'école de
commerce de nicolet l'adecec accord ceux
qui ne voient là et ça se passe
extrêmement bien c'est une fille
brillante alaba essec adore
mais il faut savoir que 1 il va vous
raconter des trucs et de l'intox est en
train de m'en tombent d'ailleurs aimé
coûte rien et ils viendront raconter oui
elle a volé que jamais la ville sale
histoire mais jamais de l'indre il va
nous raconter elle revient bien jamais
de la vie mais même quand bien même
comme jamais de la vie station de métro
diffamé c'est insupportable
ça va se rajouter d'un plainte pénale
c'est juste une jeune fille qu'ils ont
rencontrés ils ont ils l'ont rencontré
ils sont amusés la cuisine d'un
appartement lui et un complice l'on a
tiré dans le dressing pour coucher avec
elle et nous propose une couche avec aix
qu'elle me dit en tout cas sa version et
à ce moment là elle refuse elle refuse
de façon comme ils sont deviennent
insistant elle refuse et les insultes l
urne ils sortent ensemble ça continue à
hurler sans ça qu'on les voit un moment
donné il s'adresse à cri etc il rentre
effectivement dans cette salle et là
dessus il se met à l'abattre à lui
cracher dessus on entend dans la vidéo
effectivement je la crains que je vais
du crash et comme toi tu lui a craché
dessus donc il reconnaît qu'il lui a
craché dessus aussi il s'amuse à effet
très rire c'est très très drôle bien sûr
on sait et du coup cette pauvre jeune
femme s'est retrouvée à nouveau tiré par
les cheveux de l'autre côté à la fin et
ils ont essayé de la dissuader à nouveau
de saisir la police parce qu'elle a dit
je vais appeler la police et à ce moment
là ils ont tiré à tirer vers le balcon
fourmisien 90 ne fait surtout pas ça là
ils ont pris peur ils ont pris
conscience de la gravité des faits et à
ce moment là sur le balcon ils ont
essayé de vraiment de lui dire qu'elle
était attention tu es musulmane tu peux
pas faire ça tu sais très bien que tu as
pas vrai de sortie tu abuses tu a déposé
une plainte auprès effectivement de la
police faisaient très mal que toi même
tu risques quelque chose c'est ce
qu'elle me dit en tout cas et j'en suis
persuadé je la crois et après elle s'est
rendu en sortant de l'appartement à
l'ambassade et tenez vous bien tenez
vous bien devinez ce que l'ambassade lui
a dit ce que lui aurait dit
effectivement l'ambaq saxe et écouter
n'allait pas déposé plainte vous n'avez
pas la preuve donc merci à celui qui a
de cette vidéo qui a cru effectivement
enfoncé ma cliente qui finalement ça va
me permettre de prouver ce qui s'est
passé et tout ce qu'elle me dit depuis
des mois mais c'est vrai que quand vous
n'avez pas de preuve c'est compliqué
donc maintenant que j'ai la preuve je
peux vous dire que je me rate je vais
pas la rater je veux pas les rater tous
ces gens là parce que ça suffit cette
vidéo dangereuse mais dangereuse et je
tiens à rappeler à ce monsieur qui sera
sur le plateau qui reste quand même
trois ans d'emprisonnement pour
violences volontaires en réunion c'est
trois ans d'emprisonnement 45000 euros
d'amendé voilà les peines encourues et
puis les petits et complice là qui font
les vidéos il risque aussi gros et puis
la non-assistance à personne en danger
il y en a un qui a fait son mea culpa
vous avez vu la vidéo ou pas bon là oui
voilà qui fait son mea culpa parce qu'il
reconnaît qu' on sait bien à xare cette
pauvre jeune fille et ça ça va me servir
aussi comme vidéo donc merci à tous ceux
là alors je vous propose maintenant
c'est vrai plaisir c'est qu'on est la
version de hicham et après ce que
voulait revenir à bas quand vous voyez
la journée en face en noir votre version
premium revient terrain
pourront revenir l'ail
non mais alors il ya une petite question
si comme vous le dites il ya eu violence
et tentative de rapports sexuels non
consentis pourquoi ces jeunes hommes se
sont si bas et des tentatives de heures
à penser qu'il faut pas interpréter ils
ont essayé de coucher avec elle et ils
ont proposé de coucher d'accord alors à
quoi ils se seraient filmés eux mêmes
puisque cette vidéo constitue donc une
preuve contre eux non ces tests avant
non mais la scène et compromettantes
pour aussi baveux qui envient et qu'ils
ont fait c'est pas les personnes qui ont
proposé ces pépins de confirmer c'est
une bande de héros on voit qu'ils sont
quatre en tout cas ils sont conscients
d'être filmé sur la vidéo irritent au
tir et son complice tant mieux ça va
râler ou décemment dossier moi je
conçois cana qui sont là qui ont été
témoins de coûts qui ont regardé qui ont
filmé mais c'est pas forcément la scène
qui s'est passé avant n'est pas
forcément on peut pas mettre les gens
géant en matière pénale attention ne pas
aviser tout le monde et dire à tout le
monde est complice etc c'est grave on
est sur une antenne extrêmement écoutez
donc ne pas dire ça tout simplement
honteux et ce qui est certain ce qui ce
marais et ça c'est pas drôle et c'est
punissable alors oui on va poser toutes
les questions à m novakovic pour honorer
les cham et après on y reviendra oui de
m ont dit que il ya le début de la vidéo
est aussi la suite de la vidéo qui
pourrait sortir très bientôt est ce que
vous êtes au courant de ce que vous avez
vu ces vies décès etc sinon je n'ai pas
vu mes mais tout expliquer donc je pense
que c'est ça c'est quand il lui il
tracte avec elle après sur le balcon en
disant écoute n'y va pas on va pas
déposer plainte il se met à lui est cher
il y avait le visage
lire nettoyer tout payant et égalité
bout et de crachats et oussalah progrès
de gamine des bleus un jet de transsene
nationale a et bleus ont tout de suite
puisque l'affairé mais non est celle en
sortant de cette affaire et s'est rendu
à l'ambassade tout de suite d'accord
pour déposer plainte et ils lui ont dit
à l'ambassade il lui aurait dit à
l'ambassade il n'ya pas effectivement de
preuves vous n'avez pas de vidéo une
abeille rien donc sans preuve c'est très
compliqué effectivement de déposer
plainte c'est de se compliquer et
sachant qu'après elle repartait elle
partait loin en voyage effectivement
donc si elle pouvait pas matière à le
faire ok j'ai été saisi par les parents
caen est elle même bon aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui des lettres
saisies non j'ai été saisi aujourd'hui
j'avais été saisis déjà parler manger
aujourd'hui oui et vous avez déjà tout
vrai bien des gestuelles qui est bien le
dossier mais je connais mon métier
série que vous avez été saisies
aujourd'hui vous connaissez déjà le
dossier comme ça vit donc ses collants
bon j en ai annoncé que je sorte mon
autre éminent je juge est une toute la
veille au téléphone j'ai eu au téléphone
j'ai eu toute la journée au téléphone
j'ai eu chaud manger tout noté
strictement stricto sensu parce que je
veux pas dire des bêtises il me connaît
vous connaissez donc il n'est pas
question que je que je défende quoi que
ce soit de la vérité parce que c'est
quelque chose qui va être très lourd je
déposerai plainte avec tout ça mais sous
ces personnes vont s'expliquer devant un
juge d'instruction il faut alors on va
on va avoir un chien qui va arriver dans
un instant qui va nous dire son
sentiment vous c'est quoi parce qu'il ya
des gens qui disent il faut que si c'est
si cette histoire si votre version est
la vraie faut qu'il soit banni à vie de
toute télé khalid ibn abbâs bien sûr bel
et bien mais même ça mais ça ne suffit
pas à tous bah oui tous avec moi tous si
si ça ne vous suffit pas cette vidéo
alors on attend d'avoir la version sinon
merci je m'en fiche de ce qui dit elle
imite regarder ce qui se passe regardez
quand ils pensent qu'ils arrachent le
visage et un chien
chiens et a même un chien on traite pas
comme ça heureusement d'ailleurs parce
que c'est comme ça les manoirs et mais
en tout cas tenez vous bien est-ce que
c'est acceptable ce qu'on a vu la
regarder l'humiliation est une jeune
fille d'une vingtaine d'années c'est
énorme en choquant c'est extrêmement
choquant origine alors bien sûr tout en
choquant mais je vais me faire l'avocat
du diable enfin c'est pas si le gars
mais elle est utile à une série très
longuement au téléphone lui dit que
votre cliente elle a volé il le dit dans
la vidéo mais il me l'a reconfirmé alors
être volés énormément de religion c'est
pas une raison
et ambitions ses bagages ans et elle
vous a affirmé qu'elle n'avait pas volé
au préalable il pas que ça justifie
arriver non seulement d'avoir ya pas de
raison puisque toute façon il n'ya pas
d'effets le mobile il faut le prouver
déjà en ce deuxièmement il ya la témoin
vous c'est la jeune femme qui est là
elle fait même crainte et magnoac du
fait que c'est faux archi faux donc ya
pas de vols y'a rien s'il vient
évidemment civiles la question possible
voilà je vous pose sous conditions vous
avez été saisie du dossier aujourd'hui
quand vous pourrez aussi persuadé de
votre version là ce soit juste en une
journée voilà cette vidéo d'accord c'est
tout cette vidéo est la sincérité de ses
propos la tentative de suicide se sont
trompés en matière pénale des faisceaux
d'indicés
en fait en matière pénale avait quand
même 33 ans maggie grace en matière
pénale
quand vous avez un dossier il faut
vérifier les faits sauna dise quels sont
les indices mais vous avez cette jeune
femme qui à terre on lui crache dessus
on rigole on ya une fille tentative
effectivement de suicide vous avez une
vidéo qui diffusait façon violente
également tout ça c'est des violences
lors absolue justement